learn to bring together this is  Michael's favor doing what he does best  bringing foreign athletes to Pyongyang  to compete with North Korean athletes he  is a Canadian businessman with a  cultural exchange company based in the  northern Chinese city of dong dong he is  also the man behind the unusual  friendship between US basketball star  Dennis Rodman and North Korean leader  Kim Jung Hwan favors possibly one of the  best connected Western businesspeople in  North Korea and now nobody is exactly  sure where he is before Beijing  confirmed it was investigating favor  Canada's foreign minister confirmed  something was amiss we are aware of a  Canadian who got in touch with us  because he was being asked questions by  Chinese authorities Spader also uses his  base in China to promote investment in  North Korea but China says he is now a  security risk